lovely to see here on the corporate
Sophie now of course you've had a
fantastic season I'm sure you've got
another one to come we cannot wait but
if you had Joffrey right in front of you
now and you could say anything to him
what would you say and why you'd have to
bleep it all out if it was Jack in front
of me I give him a big hug I love him
I don't know yeah you you would have to
be full out
cuz Joffrey is a horrible horrible
person yeah I don't know how you put up
with him honestly I recently said that
Justin Bieber was like the 21st century
Joffrey what do you think the
similarities are and why is that :
III more think it's the fact that Justin
Bieber was kind of adored by girls and
for me when I was younger I always was
like oh Justin Bieber I want to marry
him and then it works sorry then it
paralleled with Sansa and Joffrey
Baratheon he's naked like Tristan is not
like a psychopathic killer like Joffrey
is I just meant it like at the beginning
of the show when people adore him and
what do you think of Circe's character
what just do you think Sansa really
thinks and what do you think of her I
think what starts that while Sansa hate
Cersei I mean she knows she's scheming
she used to look up to her and she just
as Cersei is kind of the epitome of the
fairy tale you know not being true and
Santa hates her for that for ruining her
childhood dreams
um and personally I love Cersei she's
like the coolest character on the show I
think she's got a great storyline ahead
of her she's crazy someone came up to me
the other day and they were like so so
so stupid you know so much what I was
like you have no idea because Sansa
she's been putting on this facade of her
former self she's been pretending to be
innocent and naive for the past maybe
season and people don't realize that
she's picking up all the handy hints
from Cersei and Margaery and she's
eventually gonna use them against them
whether they like it or not well maybe
not Margaery because she's a tall but
you know people like in his Cersei and
Joffrey and you know Tywin they all go
to watch the backs
Sansa's coming together big time she's
definitely growing into herself she's
not this season she kind of becomes the
real salsa as people would definitely
like to see her instead of you know
being so disillusioned by fairy tales
and princesses she definitely she
becomes kind of this woman who really
realizes that the world is not a fairy
tale life is not a fairy tale because
she's probably the most pessimistic
character on the show from now on
because she knows everything and she
knows that she can't trust anyone I mean
look how much is not for metal fingers
she she is so wise now she'd be a very
good Queen but I don't think she wants
to become Queen if it means marrying
Joffrey so for now let's leave her off
the throne but maybe and maybe maybe in
the future maybe one day she'll become
queen that would be nice if any of the
characters on the show could have their
own reality TV show who do you think it
should be and why and what would it
involve well it definitely shouldn't be
John because he'd just be like sad all
the time
Tyrion and Bronn I think people have
already discussed this I've heard people
telling me that Tyrion and bronze should
have a reality not like the producers
don't get anything from this it was like
fans that were like Tara and bran would
be a great it's been off showing
you